bonsoir à toutes et à tous
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous proposer une
petite devinette
je suis l'un des plus grands inventeurs
et scientifique de l'ère moderne mon
héritage à laisser des traces
indélébiles dans votre quotidien je suis
un insatiable curieux un travailleur
acharné je suis à l'origine de l'ampoulé
électrique du phonographe je suis je
suis tomasz edison évidemment même si
certains d'entre vous n'ont pas réussi à
l'identifier
je suis persuadé que ce nom ne vous est
pas inconnu que vous l'avez déjà entendu
au moins une fois dans votre vie sa
renommée est d'ordre mondial et pourtant
pourtant rien ne prédestinait thomass
edison intel futur en effet à l'âge de 9
ans le petit edison rentre d'une longue
journée d'école et ils adressent à sa
mère une lettre une lettre que son
professeur lui avait dit de donner à sa
mère est uniquement à sa mère celle-ci
ouvre la lettre l on découvre le contenu
et les yeux pleins de larmes elle révèle
à son fils le contenu de cette lettre
madame votre fils est un génie
nous n'avons pas suffisamment de bons
enseignants pour l'instruire et nous
vous demandons de lui trouver vous même
d'autres enseignants
imaginez vous la joie le sentiment
d'euphorie quatre jeux ressentir le
petit edison votre vie c'est un génie eh
bien ces quelques paroles ont été
suffisantes pour le propulser vers le
haut suffisante pour lui donner
suffisamment d'ardeur de persévérance et
de motivation pour atteindre ces
objectifs et devenir le grand inventeur
que nous admirons tous encore
aujourd'hui quelques années plus tard
arrivé à l'âge adulte
sa maman décède thomas edison retourne à
la maison familiale et ils recherchent
un peu dans les souvenirs de famille et
c'est là qu'il retombe sur cette fameuse
lettre cette lettre qu'il n'avait pas
lui même à l'époque il décide d'en
découvrir le contenu est abasourdi il
découvre les véritables parole et les
mots de son professeur
celui ci avait en réalité dit à sa mère
madame votre fils est nul nous avons
détecté chez lui une maladie un déficit
mental
sa mère lui a donc volontairement caché
dissimulé transformer des mises et mes
mots de son professeur les mots
décourageant de son professeur en démo
motivant des mots bienveillants des mots
propulseur des mots encourageants et ses
mots ont eu un véritable impact un
véritable pouvoir sur thomas edison car
ils ne l'ont pas limitée au contraire
ils ont tiré une
poussé vers le haut et alors est ce que
thomas ces dix années devenu un génie
grâce à sa mère la question reste à
débattre et ce qui est sûr c'est que son
niveau de motivation aurait été
différent si sa mère lui avait révélé
les véritables maux de son professeur
d'ailleurs lui-même dit par la suite
thomas edison était certes un enfant nul
est déficient mais il est devenu le
génie du siècle grâce à une mère
héroïque
vous l'aurez compris aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous parler de l'importance
que revêt notre vocabulaire
non seulement à notre égard mais
également à l'égard des autres des
personnes qui nous entourent de notre
environnement les mots en effet ont une
influence énorme sur off certains mots
sont agréables à entendre lorsque je dis
à ma meilleure amie qu'elle est très
jolie et bien je vois directement que ce
mot jolie les procure un sourire
d'ailleurs c'est la vérité est une
satisfaction un regain de confiance en
elle alors que d'autres mots sont
complètement destructeur certains mots
en effet nous blesse profondément et
créé de profondes et impénétrable
blessure car certains mots voyez vous
c'est humiliant vexant et nous en avons
toutes et tous déjà été le destinataire
on connaît toutes et tous une personne
dans notre offre dans notre entourage
une personne toxiques qui rien qu'avec
de simples paroles réussi à provoquer en
nous un sentiment de mal être un
sentiment de complexe en ce sens nous
mêmes
je n'ai pas assez bien tu es nul tu
aurais pu mieux faire je suis mieux que
toi ce sont des gens qui existent
malheureusement et que nous devons
éviter car leurs paroles leurs mots vexe
et sont blessants ils peuvent même vous
détruire et d'ailleurs les mots sont
tellement influent que la plupart des
mots que l'on a entendu dans notre
enfance continue aujourd'hui encore à
avoir un impact sur nous à nous orienter
à nous guider à un son ans et nos
actions
vous l'aurez compris certains mots son
guérisseur alors que d'autres rendu
malade les mots sont aussi dures que
certains coûts on dit parfois que les
mots sont des pistolets chargés
de façon plus poétique je pourrais vous
dire que les mots sont l'eau qui irrigue
le souffle qui fait vivre et la pluie
qui dévastent les mots sont d'autant
plus importants qu'il reflète également
notre identité notre personnalité en
effet notre façon de parler mais peu le
reflet de normes de notre manière d'être
je vais vous prendre un exemple très
simple
beaucoup d'entre vous j'en suis sûr ont
déjà fait la connaissance de personnes
via les réseaux sociaux la première
étape pour appréhender leur leur
personnalité et systématiquement de
vérifier de checker un peu leur profil
facebook installent g pour regarder
quelles images ces personnes renvoi
mais en réalité êtes vous pleinement et
totalement fixé sur la personnalité
d'une personne après avoir épluché son
réseau sur son profil sur les réseaux
sociaux
confucius disait une image vaut mieux
que mille mots mais c'est là que je suis
en total désaccord avec lui si nous
voulons véritablement
décortiqué appréhender connaître et
partager découvrir explorer la
personnalité d'une personne nous avons
besoin d'une discussion d'un échange
verbal avec elle car les mots que nous
prononçons ne sont que le reflet de ce
que nous sommes
les mots permettent alors de refléter
notre identité notre personnalité ce que
nous disons sur autrui nantis pas tant
sur eux que sur nous mêmes nous sommes
ce que nous dit ce que me disent on je
vais vous prendre un autre exemple
imaginez que vous êtes en train d'avoir
une discussion avec une personne et
cette personne vous parle de sa
meilleure amie vous vous attendez à
entendre des phrases bienveillante et
gagnante à l'égard de son année les en
réalité votre interlocutrice vous dis oh
mais cette fille c'est vraiment une
catastrophe
elle est pitoyable elle est mauvaise
elle est ridicule je la supporte pas
vous aurez retenu deux choses de cette
discussion premièrement l'ami de votre
interlocutrice est probablement une
personne ridicule pathétique méchante
c'est possible deuxièmement est le plus
important votre interlocutrice n'est pas
une personne de confiance n'est pas une
personne fidèle loyal car si elle est
capable de prononcer les pires atrocités
du monde sur sa meilleure amie devant
vous mais imaginez-vous alors ce qu'elle
pourrait dire à votre propos dans votre
dos vous le voyez bien les mots ne sont
que le reflet de notre identité éléments
sont d'autant plus importants
aujourd'hui dans une société qui enferme
des individus dans des catégories dans
des cases qui distribue les étiquettes à
tout va et cette étiquette elle nous est
attribuée par les mots que nous
utilisons lorsque vous dites à une
personne je suis étudiant en droit ces
quelques mots étudiant en droit
suffisent pour vous distribuez laquelle
la netiquette d'un juriste en herbe
alors que vous en êtes encore à étudier
les principes généraux du droit les mots
nous donne notre place dans cette
société il nous donne notre identité
sociale mais bien plus que de distribuer
des étiquettes ou de dresser des
portraits des personnalités des profils
les mots sont véritablement propulseur
dans notre vie car chaque mots que nous
employons à sa propre énergie et c'est
pourquoi nous devons utiliser des mots
qui sont en lien direct avec nos
objectifs
il y en ait fait une différence évidente
entre une personne qui se répète
inlassablement je suis nul je n'y arrive
pas c'est vraiment c'est la catastrophe
pour que j'abandonne c'est j'arrête
j'arrête je suis né je ne suis pas à la
hauteur et une personne qui va se dire à
elle-même
je vais y arriver coûte que coûte
j'atteindrai mes objectifs je suis forte
et je vais le faire
alors que la première personne ce
programme psychologiquement à l'échec la
deuxième personne elle mais se met dans
les meilleures conditions pour atteindre
ces objectifs et cela a été prouvé
scientifiquement
car nous disposons toutes et tous ici
d'une zone cérébrale appelée système
réticulaire d'activation et cette zone
permet de sélectionner toutes les
informations que nous recevons chaque
jour pour ne sélectionner que celles qui
sont importants pertinente intéressante
à notre égard que celles qui sont en
rapport avec notre pensée avec nos mots
avec nos expressions avec ce que nous
disons je reprends l'exemple du départ
une personne qui va se répéter hommes et
ma vie c'est no run j'ai vraiment pas de
chance
et bien son système d'activation
réticulaire va sélectionner cette
information et se consacrer uniquement
sur les aspects négatifs de sa vie
quitte à laisser de côté tous les
bienfaits dont nous disposons le simple
fait de respirer le simple fait d'être
en vie le simple fait de pouvoir se
lever tous les matins d'accomplir
quelque chose de devenir quelque chose
pourquoi devrions nous laisser cela de
côté alors que ce sont ces choses qui
pourront nous permettre de devenir
quelqu'un
utilisons dès aujourd'hui des mots qui
sont en lien direct avec ce que nous
aimons avec ce que nous voulons faire
maître yoda avez raison on ne peut pas
soit essayer quelque chose soit tu fais
quelque chose soit tu ne le fait pas
mais arrêtons de dire je vais essayer
nous devons dès aujourd'hui dire je vais
le faire je peux le faire ce sont ces
mots forts ces mots positifs ces mots
lumineux et rayonnant qui provoqueront
en nous un sentiment de motivation qui
nous permettront d'atteindre un niveau
d'engagement supérieur et qui nous
permettront de trouver la force pour
nous lever
réussir nos objectifs les mots son
propulseur et j'en suis la preuve
vivante
pour vous expliquer je dois reprendre
une histoire du début
depuis toute petite j'ai toujours été
considéré comme de la part de mes
ordonné de mes parents de mes
professeurs comme l'élève qui réussirent
à des études de médecine et qui
deviendra médecin on n'a jamais demandé
mon avis on a juste dit toi on te voit
en médecine et tu dois aller en médecine
dans nature un peu influençable je me
suis laissé guider par ses directions et
après l'obtention de mon baccalauréat
c'est naturellement que je me suis
orientée en médecine et quel était mon
objectif
mon objectif était d'avoir ma première
année de paces pour cette satisfaire les
exigences et les attentes que les autres
avaient deux mois
après une première année difficile où
j'ai beaucoup travaillé j'ai eu une
opportunité de redoubler j'ai saisi ma
chance et je me suis dit ah cette fois
c'est la bonne tu auras ta première
année de paces
mais ce redoublement voyez-vous a
constitué un véritable déclic dans ma
vie
parce que c'est grâce à ce redoublement
que je me suis rendu compte que ma place
n'était pas en médecine que j'ai passé
que je passais à côté d'une belle et
grande opportunité et que mon rêve le
plus profond en moi que je cachais
depuis des années était de devenir
avocate de faire des études de droit
mais j'avais peur j'avais peur de me re
vrai orienté et je gardais ce sentiment
bien profond tâche et sans poser de mots
là-dessus
mais un jour la cocotte minute a explosé
la veille des examens de ce semestre de
ce semestre de passe est j'avais besoin
d'évacuer tout cela j'avais besoin de
mettre des mots de m'exprimer j'ai
trouvé en master la meilleure des
confidentes je lui ai dit je ne suis pas
heureuse en paces je ne veux pas devenir
médecin je veux et je vais être avocate
ces quelques mots semblent peut-être
anodin pour vous mais pour moi ils ont
constitué un véritable tournant ces
quelques mots m'ont permis de prendre
conscience de la réalité de l'accepter
ces quelques mots ont provoqué un
sentiment de détermination en moi de
persévérance et ce sentiment n'a permis
d'agir de me réorienter et aujourd'hui
j'ai l'honneur de vous dire que je suis
en 3e année de droit il me reste encore
un long chemin à faire des hauts et des
bas surmonter mais je suis dans une voie
qui me plaît où je suis épanoui et où je
suis moi même enfin et ce dont je me
souviendrai toujours voyez vous c'est le
comportement qu'a eu ma soeur à mon
égard et les mots qu'elle a choisi de
m'adresser c'est pas grave n'aura je
vais être capable de le faire tu peux le
faire il n'y a rien de mal à se
réorienter n'ai pas peur et confiance
c'est cette attitude que nous devons
adopter toutes et tous les uns envers
les autres car si nous voulons changer
le monde nous devons nous changer nous
mêmes nous devons changer notre
vocabulaire nous devons prêter attention
à chaque mots que nous employons
utilisons des mots doux des mots
lumineux rayonnant pour un autre tour
être le reflet de toute cette lumière
vous pourriez un jour alors me dire oui
mais c'est pas parce que je répète
inlassablement bonheur bonheur bonheur
que je serais heureuse ou que je répète
tristesse tristesse tristesse que je
serai triste et bien un spectateur un
jour a posé la même question à un
speaker qui était à ma place et qui
portait les mêmes propos que moi et ce
dernier lui a dit monsieur vous êtes
incompétent votre question n'est pas
relevantes je ne veux je ne vais même
pas l'écouter vous ne méritez même pas
d'être la sorte et
l'effroi que ces paroles ont provoqué
dans la salle était incroyable le pauvre
spectateur s'est sentie complètement
irrespectueux menton et a senti qu'on
lui avait manqué de respect
mais le dow jones qui régnait dans
l'amphithéâtre a commencé à s'agiter on
entendait des murmures partout et dans
ce coup l'orateur lui a dit on et
monsieur je m'excuse je m'excuse
vraiment de ses paroles mon but n'était
pas de vous offenser je vous présente
mes plus plates et humbles excuses
veuillez vraiment me comprendre je suis
un peu stressé mais votre question était
tout à fait intéressante je m'excuse
véritablement et sincèrement ces
quelques paroles ces quelques mots doux
ont été suffisants pour établir la paix
sociale au sein de l'amphithéâtre
l'individu avait donc sapera sa réponse
à sa question il avait suffi de quelques
mots et de méchants pour provoquer
l'effroi dans la salle et il a décidé de
quelques mots doux bienveillant pour
rétablir une paix une harmonie au sein
de cette salle vous l'aurez compris mais
mort est soyons vigilants avec les mots
que nous employons à la fois notre égard
et à l'égard des autres car les mots
sont peut être pardonné mais ils ne sont
pas oubliés et aujourd'hui j'aimerais
vous adresser quelques mots en plus de
ce que je viens de vous prononcer vous
qui que vous soyez pour que vous soyez
vous êtes fort vous pouvez accomplir des
choses ayez confiance en vous et vous
arriverez à accomplir vos des objectifs
et à transformer votre avenir
j'espère que ces mots que j'ai prononcés
aujourd'hui
resteront gravés dans votre mémoire qui
vous illumineront et feront ce ressortir
le meilleur en chacun d'entre eux
[Applaudissements]